we got this story from human events
breaking from jack pasobi
leaked state department memo indicates
official
support for black lives matter agenda do
you want to know what one of their
agenda items is
disrupting the nuclear family is that
part of the biden administration
i mean the dude's already a racist
according to federal courts right he's
biden this is the this is the craziest
thing the bite administration
has implemented relief pro relief funds
for
restaurants only if you're not white
though if you're right back of the line
so what happened is this one guy sues
the problem
they already gave out billions of
dollars so they have decided
illegally violation of the 1964 civil
rights act and
unconstitutionally to give money on the
basis of race
and you can sue them and you can stop
them but they already did it
so what well and by the way biden is the
greatest trojan horse
ever and here's why they got the oldest
whitest guy in the entire world to be
the one who's out there pushing critical
race theory
and official support for black lives
matter because
joe biden's not running this show you
know i mean and
the the scary thing to me is and this
like sounds like such a crazy conspiracy
theorist
the crazy thing to me is like i know
that joe biden's not running this show
and i know kamala harris isn't running
the show so i'm always up with
who's actually making decisions in this
because
there's really insidious stuff that's
happening somebody is being very
effective at their job we just don't
know who it is but
maybe not could it be that joe biden is
so pathetic and weak that
black lives matter stuff can just waltz
right in yeah but
like somebody the way that this
somebody's making these decisions
somebody is saying at some level
institutionally
let's make this part of this i think you
know so the the alternative
it doesn't have to be one person who's
in charge by the way but the alternative
to the conspiracy theory is the
standalone complex
which is a bunch of people doing the
same thing that looks like a conspiracy
yeah
i really do think that it's not so much
that we're looking at a nucleus and
control
because biden certainly does not exude
nucleus and control
i think we're looking at the opposite a
fracturing
and confusion and the only thing people
know is what's in the news
and the news is woke woke so they're
just like
woke i guess and but it's also kind of
like a mexican standoff
so you have a lot of people who probably
hate wokeness but they're scared of
speaking out because
they think they'll get canceled so what
you have is 100 people in a room
all going i i'm woke i'm woke but deep
down they're all anti-woke
but they're scared other people are woke
you see what it is
so i don't i don't i don't see it as a
grand conspiracy because it's too
ridiculous and nonsensical well and in a
way
this may be the opposite side of the
coin that trump had when it came to
staffing
trump's number one issue was staffing he
relied on
the establishment think tanks in dc to
fill out his like mid-level and
low-level political appointees
the result was a whole bunch of people
who didn't believe trump
who didn't like trump and who took it
upon themselves to run their own little
fiefdoms
the biden administration the
progressives may have just done a really
great job at making sure their people
are the people who got
hired the people the true believers
ended up there
you know i mean it's not it's not the
rahm emanuel
disciples who are in charge in the biden
administration
i called it i liken it to fire in that
it's just an expansion
expansive chaotic and destructive force
that once it grabs onto something that
can fuel its fire it does
so it's fairly random and it's spreading
into the military it's spreading into
the state department to the federal
reserve which is like one of the
weirdest stories
do we have that yeah we have that one
right here look at this senate
republicans expand investigation into
woke
mission creep of federal reserve now
that is the scariest thing because i'll
tell you i'll tell you one thing and
ian you know he knows this you can
complain about the government being woke
and we can argue about it oh this is bad
when the federal reserve gets woke
then i started i'm getting worried
exactly trouble yeah makes me think that
it is
intentional i keep thinking about the
great reset and the bank of
international settlements which
basically oversees the federal reserve
the bank of england the bank of
australia
and like it's it's not a no government
has any oversight of what these
organizations are doing the great reset
has blatantly said that they want to
i don't know how you describe it but
destroy the economic order and reinstill
a new world where we own nothing and
that we're all kind of
subservient and everything's given to us
on loan by some
some greater that like just is popping
on and off i don't know if that matters
ian you will own nothing and you will be
happy well i hope that that's not the
case but dear lord
uh and it seems like they're sowing
dissent within the united states to
break it up because the greatest
resistance is
this liberty that we've got i just don't
think it's a conspiracy
i think it's there's no more strong
leaders
there's no more social and moral
cohesion and so
it's i i i don't think there's a strong
powerful cabal of people that want to
break it apart i think it's a bunch of
people
grabbing you know money from the vault
as the building's on fire
i i would refer to that time magazine
article that
specifically the shadow camera is a
cabal of people that are intentionally
see what the media does well i'll say
this much
my colleague brent hammerscheck at uh
human events wrote a really awesome
article about how we're now all
dissidents the conservatives were
dissidents and
he's got this great thing where
everybody always talks about like well
there's
more of us than them who cares that
there's more of us
than them because they control all of
the the levers of power
in this country big businesses run by
the left
academia is run by the left pop culture
is run by the left like
they they're in control of everything so
it doesn't take a conspiracy theory what
it takes is
is it takes a handful it takes a group
of people
who are all thinking the same way who
also happen to occupy
the most powerful positions in the
country i mean
we always talk about like fox news
that's great we have like one
fox news compare what the and fox news
does great
but compare like what fox news news
viewership is
to what all the other left-wing media
outlets are
and then you realize fox looks like this
and all of the left-wing organizations
look like
that i mean it is it's a it is
i think we've been lulled into this
sense of believing that because there's
more of
us than them that that somehow is going
to save us and it's
not so ian's certainly not a
conservative
and not really sometimes depends on the
situation i don't i don't think there's
a sane argument for saying you're a
conservative
i can certainly say you have libertarian
overlapping
the death penalty that's kind of a
conservative yeah
for sure i'm hardcore when it comes to
military discipline
and stuff wow i didn't realize the hip
ian hippie guy was like kill them all
the authoritarian out tim um i don't
know i i'm just i don't think of myself
as
liberal or i'm both liberal in certain
situations which need it and
conservative when we want conservation
and and
to maintain and retain my point is uh
conservatives certainly call me
left-wing but left-wings call me
conservative because
obviously i'm kind of in the middle and
so the conservatives actually have
allies with disaffected liberals and
moderates liberal people who have
actually watched the news surprise
surprise end up joining like
the likes of the intellectual dark web
or becoming fans of it but most of these
people
just watch msnbc now here's the problem
there may be more of us on the freedom
and individualism side
than the constructivism collectivism
side however if we got a 100 people
on this side of which 20 have spines
and they have 40 people on that side of
which 30 have spines
they're going to win those battles over
and over and over again i i can't tell
you how many celebrities i've talked to
who are like well actually i can't
probably like 10 or 12
who are like i you know i believe
everything you say i'm a big fan of the
show but i can't speak up because i'll
lose everything and i'm like then you
don't deserve
anything correct you get to you get to
what you're saying is
when you tell me this guys when you call
me you tell me this
you're telling me that you're okay
extracting value from the system
to live lavishly because let's be real
you guys are rich
you're not suffering like the average
american and you won't give up your
silver spoon to save your own country
fine then you don't deserve it and what
what what's what was anyone going to do
because they'll certainly wield the
power not not only do the left of
celebrities will the power
but even leftist celebrities who also
don't like it
will just toe the line if it means cash
in the bank yeah and also afraid that
they'll come for them
i mean look look at how many times that
the the left has eaten one of their own
they'll they'll do it you know i mean
the
the the the they have no problem
sacrificing one of their own
if it means it keeps a hundred more of
them in line
man it's like who would want to be part
of the borg you know the metaphor i keep
thinking is the russian
world war ii the russians and the
germans and there were
so many more russians as far as i know
but
and there were so much fewer germans but
they had better technology
whereas you see these people on the left
have access to the media they have the
better technology they have the
the tanks the blitz creek and then all
these other people
are are you know technologically maybe
in less less empowered
the russians only won that war well it's
complicated but they were allies
external allies and they also won by war
of attrition
by this by destroying what they love
burning their own courts
yeah exactly i mean they could suffer
the most losses in the war so it's not
it's the zap bran against strategy
that sending wave after a wave of your
own men until
you just overrun the enemy they were
like mass-produced trash tanks
the the communist method was really just
let the people die
just just mowing people into it the the
capitalist and american strategy was
have the efficient machine have the
efficient strategy so we have air
superiority and nuclear bombs that means
we minimize the risk to ourselves the
communists
load them all up and send them out and
just sacrifice wave after waiting
they didn't compare just grind them all
up just grind them all
it worked so it did it's not pretty for
only for only some amount of time
certain amount of time
yeah it may not be a good metaphor
because if if the people on the right
were the the communi
it's just this ridiculous outside of the
box metaphor but like the cancel culture
thing of just like
keep going with it keep saying what
might get you banned online and then
they keep
one by one taking these people out it's
just i think
i think this metaphor is not good well
it's only it's only
thanks for bearing with it that was fun
yeah it's only a matter of time
uh because they control the institutions
until
everybody's been so what you crashed the
code the allies cracked the code
that gave them some google facebook
twitter
they are slowly making excuses to purge
people and they have
it it's this is what happens when you
have a religion
that is violent oppressive and extreme
christians aren't that and you know the
nazis violent
excessive and extreme actually ate
themselves from the inside out
as you can see the celeste is doing they
tried to kill hitler like their own the
own
people tried to murder him and that
basically drove hitler insane and then
made him make start making poor
decisions of leadership it's extremists
and then they fell apart
as a so you could see maybe see that
happening to this
wokeness too i could see that they i
mean they obviously go after each other
like you were saying earlier
and i mean i really do it's one i'm not
always the most optimistic guy about
this stuff like i think politically
in the short term i think we're gonna i
think we're gonna feel the pain
for a while and even if republicans win
back the house and the senate
i have no i don't know i have no faith
in these people
none at all so but long term i do feel
like that this like woke
like push is going to undermine
democrats because again like i said
until we pass my amendment to outlaw
suburban women from being able to
vote like they they matter and this this
critical race theory stop being until
then
right this critical race theory stuff
that's being pushed in public schools
like this is the type of stuff and
democrats are starting to warn liberal
thinkers are starting to warn democrats
you've got a lot of problems here you've
got prop like you
are gonna disaffect that base that you
just relied on to get elected
by pushing this critical race theory
stuff you run around teaching that this
country is fundamentally
a racist country that it's you know that
we're still a fundamentally racist
country that we're founded on
racism it's not simply teaching yes
slavery was terrible and the lessons
learned from that and
jim crow was terrible but that somehow
we're beyond saving
this country is just garbage it's really
i got a really simple solution for
everybody
if you work for one of these companies
or you are a member of a school board or
you have kids in one of these schools
and you hear critical critical theory in
general
file a complaint with the appropriate
administration or organization
so uh if you work for a company and they
announce they're doing critical race
theory trainings
or if another employee brings up
critical race theory
report them for racial harassment
immediately i'm not exaggerating
you go to your boss and say janet came
and started spouting a bunch of racist
stuff
and i demand you tell her to stop
otherwise i will file a complaint you
have been warned
and then you know what they'll do
they'll say janet stop the racist stuff
and she'd go i was arguing against her
i don't care what it is stop it people
are getting mad that's why you have to
use their own language against them
that's why when whenever i see somebody
like talking about critical race theory
like yes you accuse them of being racist
because that's what they are but that's
but it's i won't do it though they're
like oh critical race theory is it's a
kind of bad thing it's like you know
like
rather than saying like this is racist
if you work for a company here i'll tell
you what i would do because we talked
about this last week if i worked for a
company and the boss was like we're
doing a racial sensitivity training
i would be like oh it's gonna be great
and i would go in and no matter what
they say
i would get offended if there was there
was a training video i guess i think
i think this was was from coke or
something i remember i heard this but
someone was talking to me about
in the training it explained racial
stereotypes it was like people often
think latinos are lazy and said a bunch
of things
unlike if you're latino you should
immediately say excuse me
did we just get invited to your clan
rally so you can explain to people
why people think latinos are lazy and
then they'll have to shut it down
you here's how it works you give your
boss a warning
and if they don't rectify the problem
then you inform them you're filing a
complaint with the equal employment
opportunity commission i think it's
called eeoc
and then you go and file the complaint
now again i've mentioned this before
maybe someone at the administration at
the eoc is going to be super welcome
they tell you to go screw yourself and
that's where it starts getting bad
but for the time being he's going and
you don't even got to be specific
you don't got to be listen if there was
a guy
and he's a boss and he's like a white
progressive guy and he's like we're
going to be doing you know critical race
theory diversity training i'd be like if
you do that i will be filing a complaint
and then when i file the complaint i'll
say he started spouting a bunch of
extremely racist sentiment talking about
how some people of certain races
were inherently bad or wrong and it was
bad to look this way and have this
colored skin
what did he say specifically i can't
repeat it don't make me say it
that's it go to the boss go above your
go go above your boss and say
he said a bunch of racist things what
did he say i will not repeat it but i
have warned you he is harassing and is
racist
people need to do this because guess
what it's not about using the language
of the left
it's about you could be sitting there
and being like man that that uh that
chris rock's a phony guy excuse me
and then they go and complain about
cultural appropriation and then your
boss is going to be like you really got
to chill out on the racist stuff you're
like wait what i didn't say anything
well they complained about you being
racist so
if they bring it up complain about it
the problem is our side has
traditionally sucked at this
you know i mean because by the way
because most of us just want to be left
alone
you know we just want to do our own
thing like fine you have opinions
i i don't really like them whatever it
doesn't change my life
but you're right we can no longer just
sit back and let that happen
and because the fact that we've allowed
ourselves to be rolled over
to the point where it's not okay we're
we're not allowed to have opinions
anymore that
that they don't like i mean as if you're
not willing to fight back
you know i agree you know you know what
really bothers me i i go through
i go through like a uh some phases when
i watch bullying right
so i see a kid getting bullied and the
first thing i get mad about is the bully
leave that dude alone what's wrong with
you and then
after like the tenth time you know i get
mad at the kid getting bullied you know
why
bro at a certain point you've got to
change what's happening you can't keep
walking up to the bully stop walking
this direction
stop going to the school or stand up for
yourself
but at a certain point if you don't
stand up for yourself after
all of this i won't defend you i'll get
mad i'll say you're on your own and so
i've talked about this with police
like the cops in in in the minneapolis
area they're getting defunded in
brooklyn center and you know what i'm
not going to defend him sorry
i defended him before the election what
did we see in philadelphia they're
experiencing one of the worst crime
surges ever
so they re-elect in a landslide their
progressive soft
on crime d.a well let's keep doing our
fire hot but let's try it again maybe
fire not hot this time
i'm not gonna defend the people of
philadelphia i'm not gonna defend those
cops if they stick around and they get
locked up for you know trying to arrest
somebody
and look at first i'm gonna be like
these people burning on these cities are
awful they're bad they must be stopped
then i watch in a landslide victory the
democrats vote in the politicians who
supported the riots and i'm like okay
it's all yours
have a nice day yeah let no let the rich
white people experience
what they they bought it you know they
paid for it let them have it
like you look if that's if that's what
you want and but none of them actually
want that
right none of them want that but because
they're all living in their states and
they're in the nice areas of town and
they're like
they think they're immune from this but
you know what's happening now wall
street general reported
the areas that have experienced the
worst sergeant crime black neighborhoods
latino neighborhoods of course not
affecting the white progressive suburbs
no so take away their cops take them
they want to abolish the police you get
what you ask for because i'll tell you
what
i live in the middle of nowhere you know
we got guns we're good
uh i'd prefer if it wouldn't have to be
this way but if they're advocating for
abolishing the police i'm gonna take
responsibility for myself
but going back to the stuff about
critical theory it's not just race
there's critical gender theory it's
critical theory
as a whole which is this marxist
philosophy frankfurt school etc
it's really really simple you see a
flyer on the wall that says
white privilege or anything like that
you immediately file an anonymous
complaint about racial harassment from
the individual who put it up
don't don't you don't got to get
specific you can say they were spouting
racist things
disparaging people on the basis of their
race it's a violation of the 1964 civil
rights act
and i'm upset about i think it's title
vii and if they don't rectify it
you can file a complaint and they will
get in trouble
in new york it's particularly serious if
you live in new york
city it's a 250 thousand dollar fine
if they do not stop this behavior
so you warn your boss say you work at
starbucks and they're like we're gonna
have to talk about white privilege no
you're not because if you say one more
word
i will file a complaint for racial
harassment they'll be like
uh uh say it i told you not to harass me
and then go file a complaint and say
they were making
you know harassing people at the base of
the race saying some employees were
better than others on the basis of their
race
some were worse than others boom 250k
out of their pocket that's not even
using their own tactics
that's just the law and it's a law that
today
the 1964 civil rights act basically
everybody agrees with
it should be illegal to discriminate on
the basis of race except for the woke
left
nobody's fighting though yeah but by the
way i'm i'm 100 for using their own
tactics
but but look i wish we lived in a place
where the you know cancer culture didn't
exist
but as long as cancer culture exists
then i'm for canceling liberals
i see this on twitter all the time when
people are like stop celebrating this
person got fired because they had this
position no i'm going to celebrate
every single time one of theirs goes
down i'm going to celebrate
because again this is a war of attrition
and until they start feeling some of the
pain
they're not going to change the policies
aren't going to change they're not going
to change what they're doing
until enough of them start feeling the
pain of it
no i i don't think that's i don't think
that's going to work
they sacrifice their own they cancel
their own they do but eventually
look eventually it's going to start and
we've seen it a little bit
you know when there'd be the like you
know recently the woman who was the
hamas
terrorist supporter the eighth so yeah
and ap
who lost their job and they're like you
know all these reporters are like this
is so terrible that somebody can't have
their own
opinion blah blah blah it's like where
were you guys like every
any conservative in the entire world
gets fired for having you know
objectional opinions
this woman is actually a supporter of
terrorism and you're angry that she lost
her
her job could it could have sworn
marjorie taylor green got stripped over
committees for things she said years
before she got elected
yes amazing yeah amazing how that is but
again like
let them feel the pain from it you know
uh i'm in favor of cancellers getting
canceled
but i'm not in favor of leftists getting
canceled for their opinions
because there's got to be a standard if
if if this is a leftist
who is actively trying to get people
fired and then they get fired i will
laugh
and say get out of here i'm not going to
help you yeah you're nuts it's like the
fire being put out by a controlled burn
we're happy about it but if it's just
some like you know dumb commie twitter
account who says something communist so
they ban them that's bad
that's really bad there's got to be a
line as so anybody who's for free speech
i'll protect their right to free speech
anybody who's not well then
you don't want my support anyway but the
problem is is that all of these people
are for cancer culture themselves
i'm saying if there is somebody who is
like pro free speech yeah
i mean unfortunately those people don't
exist on the left anymore and there's
there's a little bit
there's a decent amount uh she went
ahead you know she's for free speech
so i will absolutely defend her at every
turn for her right to speak
and say what she wants to say uh i'll
i'll defend hel tulsi gabbard
oh yeah but tulsi is like she's got more
spine than most republicans on this
stuff
i know which is which is embarrassing by
the way it's absolutely embarrassing
that the like the the progressive
democrat tulsi gabbard
yeah she's progressive she's for gun
control she's for socialized medicine
yeah
i mean she she's not conservative but
again i think this is where
some of the breakdowns on the political
partisan battles these days
aren't on these like traditional
left-right axis
you know it's not like it's a whole
bunch of are you pro-life are you
pro-choice are you pro this pro
like some of this stuff really is
crossing all of those lines
and and for us to win we need more of
the tulsi gabbard's we need more of the
tulsi gabbard saying like
you know what this is ridiculous like
lori lightfoot in chicago saying she's
only going to
give interviews to reporters of color
like
can you can you name a republican who's
called out the anti-white racism
from a politician ever i can't i don't
think so
no yeah i don't think so tulsi gabbard
said this is anti-white racism and
she but she should resign it should be
condemned everyone should come together
and it's like
yeah chelsea we know but they're not you
know they're not no one's playing fair
no they're like the republicans aren't
playing at all they're sitting on their
hands and the democrats are just trying
to burn it down
right well and by the way like again
this is because democrats when they get
power are willing to use
you know every every tool available to
them and our side
won't which is why i said like if we
went back to the house and senate i have
no faith
i think of it like this like you vote
you're like there's a bank
and you vote for the the democrats
because they're promising to run
you know when we were in the bank
everyone's going to get a higher
interest rate you're all going to get 10
percentage
wow and then as soon as they get in you
just watch them like going into the
vault and carrying out stacks of cash
and you're like what are you where are
you going
what's it what are you doing and then
you're like you know what
i'm gonna vote for the republican next
time because these people are just
taking money from the vault
then you vote for republicans and
they're just like sitting on
on the toilet on their phones and you
can't find them you're like what's going
on like the democrats are still
looting the vault and then they're all
just all in the bathroom on their phones
because they don't actually do their
jobs so who do you vote for
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you